first time in cleveland i saw somebody
get shot yeah that was pretty
interesting yeah you saw somebody very
shocked that was crazy
that's right
yeah that was weird yeah that was a
weird encounter yo so
we so we don't smoke weed together but
we both know that we're both like i bet
you you're high right now oh yeah yeah
me too
so we were in cleveland and i and we
were up in the hotel room and the night
before when we had ordered room service
they delivered me a quesadilla with
caesar salad dressing
that's right it also wasn't even like i
was checked out of the [ __ ] hotel
right there
yeah i was like what kind of [ __ ]
place does this oh i'm trying right
i couldn't believe it so the next night
we get upstairs and i'm like i'm not
wearing that [ __ ] casing
i go go downstairs there was a little
taco shop right across this
like right across there's a bar
but right across from the
better of tacos right
i mean i'm gonna assume so yeah so it
was right across like if i look down my
window right across the street it's
right there and i go hey man i go ahead
go go get us some food
and he was like all right
and so i'm in the room and like
five minutes later i just here
and i was like
because if you know what a gun sounds
like you know what a gun sounds like
and i was like
holy [ __ ] and it was right from under
the window right where
he was supposed to be
and so like yo if you have kids you know
that's the longest walk to that window
because i have to look out the he's not
answering his phone i have to look out
the [ __ ] blind and i'm like
and i open up the blind and there was a
body in the alley
not not him
and i [ __ ] get back and i call him my
phone i go hey
and he goes hey
just saw someone get shot
i'm like yeah dude
come upstairs
and he goes
while i'm waiting for the food right
it's long gotten [ __ ] food yet
and i go what i got dude someone just
gets shot he goes yeah but they're not
going to come back and shoot him again
right
and i was like no he was okay i'm
staying for the food
and you know what i'm glad i did
first of all yeah it might be true
second of all the reason i'm so happy i
stayed is because the guy walked up and
he had walked up with more bags than
what we had ordered and i was like why
why is this man bringing me extra food
he goes hey we're probably going to
close down for the night
and uh refund all these people do you
want six free bags of food and i was
like [ __ ] yes i do
so i walked out with a bunch of extra
food and uh i don't know i think it
worked out pretty well it really did
when he walked in
when he walked in i couldn't be mad
because i was like
[Music]
but i will tell you
and then and then you and i will wrap
this one up i will tell you
so
and he was a grown person at this time
that shook me so much we were each in
our own severe bed we're watching tv and
i go hey and he goes yeah i go
come come get in bed
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
24 day i'm living liquor just to make it
through another 24.
foreign
[Music]
another day another dollar howler 7 p.m
what's it going to break another bug